it's great to be joined today by Sam sax
writer reporter and co-founder of the
watchdog news website the district
Sentinel Sam last week we talked about
this DEA decision much anticipated in
many ways where they ultimately opined
that marijuana should be kept as a
Schedule one drug along with heroin
other opiates etc we talked about the
long list of reasons why this does not
seem to be a good idea if you are a
progressive who supports both
consistency with regard to drug policy
progressive values and and sort of
recognize the failings of the war on
drugs
give me your sort of top-line concern
with this is it along the medical
research side is it along the war on
drugs criminal justice side where should
we be most concerned about this decision
well both sides of that is concerning
I'd say what it's also most concerning
is the fact that the Drug Enforcement
Agency in the Department of Health and
Human Services seems to be not existing
in the same reality that the rest of us
are the DA's decision on this matter to
keep marijuana as a schedule 1 drug
alongside heroin and LSD and other drugs
that you would think are potentially far
more damaging than marijuana is based
off a recent study by the Health and
Human Services which the DEA petitioned
them to do this second to do another
study on marijuana and it's possible
medicinal value and basically HHS comes
out and says that marijuana still has a
high risk of abuse it has no known
medicinal value and that even testing
marijuana even in controlled
environments could prove to be dangerous
therefore we need to keep this as a
Schedule one drug now that just doesn't
jive with what is happening all around
the country right now where there's over
a million patients a million people in
this country who are on medicinal
marijuana there are 25 states that have
legalized marijuana for medicinal use
another four states in the District of
Columbia have
legalize it for recreational use so
there are tons of people who are using
marijuana right now as a medicine to
treat a whole number of issues from
cancer to pain to epilepsy you you hear
these stories all the time and it's it's
shocking that the DEA and the Department
of Health and Human Services for some
reason isn't understanding this there's
this insane vicious circle that exists
where most of those politicians that are
against loosening the restrictions
around this type of research and around
legalization and decriminalization as
well as the DEA and the FDA etc they all
say we're totally open to having our
minds changed about cannabis about
marijuana
we just want scientifically valid and
well controlled clinical trials done
under the investigational new drug
application paradigm the problem is that
that's a paradigm that makes it very
difficult to really do a lot of research
which in turn will make it so that we
never actually get the loosening of
restrictions it's a circle that is
completely closed and to me makes
absolutely no sense for anybody who says
I'm completely open to having my mind
changed on this here's the mechanism
through which my mind will be changed
and it's an incredibly restrictive
mechanism the University of Mississippi
right now has permission from the US
government to do this sort of research
on marijuana and this whole approach
that you just broke down it makes it
seem like this isn't settled science
like there's still a doubt whether or
not marijuana can be an effective drug
to treat a number of ailments in this
country when it is settled science in 25
states and for more than a million
people are using it and just there was
research done on Medicare Part D
recipients and they found that because a
number of Medicare Part this is a
prescription drug program a number of
people on the program are switching from
traditional painkillers and using
medicinal marijuana which has in turn
save the government something like two
hundred and thirty million dollars
recently so the effects of this not just
the people who are using it
prove that this has medicinal value but
it's also saving the government money in
the long run as more people used
marijuana to treat their elements rather
than the pharmaceutical company's
offerings and if you look at who's
behind I think this was an investigation
done by lee fong over at the intercept a
year or two ago a lot of the forces that
are lobbying against marijuana
legalization at the state level you know
it comes on a lot of ballot initiatives
or pharmaceutical companies so they have
an interest at stake here and that's
what could be one reason why you don't
see the the federal government and
policy makers moving as quickly as the
rest of the country seems to be moving
on this issue and that sort of connects
to another area where there's a huge
double standard which is that I can't
think of a sort of logically consistent
case for cigarettes and alcohol to be
legal and regulated and taxed but not
marijuana period I mean I feel like I
can say much more about that but I don't
know that I need to I I have not heard a
compelling case for why cigarettes and
alcohol should be handled the way they
are and for mayor
marijuana to be a schedule 1 controlled
substance I haven't heard one either
other than a more cynical argument of
the influence of these industries but of
the tobacco and alcohol industries but
even just just look at what you hear on
the campaign trail or we're hearing it
suppose you're not hearing much about it
anymore but this is the opioid abuse
epidemic that's hitting the country this
is a serious problem all around all
around the country you heard politicians
talking about it and not a single person
has ever died from using marijuana and
yet we're hooking people on all these
painkillers that are proving to be very
deadly for people ruining people's lives
when there are medical alternatives to a
lot of these drugs in marijuana if if
the government and policymakers would
get on board with this I mean are as I
mentioned half the country argued or
half the states in this country already
are on board with it and over a million
people already are on board with it as
well but there are serious problems with
a lot of drugs that we allow
that aren't considered schedule 1 drugs
but our farm were destructive than
marijuana not to mention a lot of those
schedule to painkillers are one of the
actual leading gateways when prescribed
by doctors that will get people hooked
on the Schedule one drug of heroin
because it ends up being much cheaper to
buy heroin on the street than to try to
convince your doctor to keep giving you
schedule 2 drug prescriptions or buying
those pills on the streets that actually
is a gateway mechanism that's
established and that that also seems to
be sort of missing from the context of
the marijuana discussion and here in
Massachusetts that's incredibly visible
as I know you know speaking of
Massachusetts there is going to be a
vote here a ballot question in November
again on on on marijuana do you believe
that those ballot initiatives and what
we've seen happen in some states are
actually going to turn the tide
federally on the status of marijuana I
mean so far there has been some pretty
significant resistance at the federal
level despite what happens in some
states without much of a choice on
matter you're right there has been a
reluctance on the part of the federal
government to to reclassify marijuana or
to just you know drop the laws from the
books and the prohibition laws from the
books but they have reacted to a lot of
these states that have chosen to
legalize marijuana recreationally by
telling their agents basically to stand
down we have of course seen some growers
and some establishments busted up but
for the most part people are allowed to
operate in a lot of these states as long
as they're operating in accordance with
the law free from a lot of federal
government intervention I think
President Obama's Justice Department is
is respecting that somewhat mainly
because you know is that really the
fight that the Justice Department wants
to take on right now given all the other
issues about prisons and you know we
imprison the most people anywhere in the
world I don't think we need to go around
busting more pot heads and they don't
think President Obama's Justice
Department is interest in that having
said that I could easily see a different
Justice Department even a
a Donald Trump Justice Department who's
a guy who's going around to having
himself as the law and order candidate
deciding that he they don't care what
all these states are doing I mean the
federal government still has is well
within its power since marijuana is
still against federal law to crack down
on all this stuff but I think the
smarter approach which which the Obama
Justice Department is sort of taken is
stand down and let these states do do
what they want last thing I want to
touch on Sam there are some who are
opposed to both the decriminalization
and legalization of recreational
marijuana who say once you open that
door there's no way to justify keeping
any drug either criminalized or or at
least sort of like a civil violation for
its recreational use I tend to resist
the slippery slope arguments unless
there's a really strong compelling case
to be made for it is there one for that
argument or is that does that not really
make sense I don't think it makes much
sense either I mean just the fact that
we we have alcohol and cigarettes legal
and we managed to resist all the rest of
the drugs from being legal also I you
know I'm somewhat sympathetic to the
argument that perhaps all drugs should
be legal I know a number of countries
around the world have experimenting with
this and have seen positive results but
you know that's going maybe pushing it a
little farther than we need to be
pushing it right now this idea of
marijuana being a gateway drug I just I
find it somewhat laughable as though
it's a unique type of gateway drug I
mean I went to college I hung out with
the kids who are doing marijuana and I
hung out with the kids who are doing
harder drugs and you can tell there
wasn't usually a link between those two
types of kids if you want to see what a
what a gateway drug is look at alcohol
and the effects that that hasn't an
individual on how that pushes an
individual to do other drugs and you
know it's just a matter I guess of the
DEA and the Department of Health and
Human Services waking up to this we
there was that infamous clip a few years
ago when jared Polis was questioning the
DEA administrator Michele Leonhart in
which she refused to say whether or not
heroin is a more destructive or more
harmful drug than marijuana yeah well
she's left and we now have Chuck
Rosenberg who is this slightly better he
admitted that heroin heroin is worse
than marijuana but yet he called
medicinal marijuana a joke so only
slightly better there still needs to be
a lot of growing up among among the
leadership over there yeah incremental
improvements I guess Sam sax writer
reporter co-founder of the district
Sentinel Sam great to talk to you thank
you yeah thanks a lot